[Music]
bindi what's it been like for you to
become a mom
watching her
soak in the world around her has been
truly magical her best friends a giant
aldabra tortoise when he sees grace he
runs across his paddock which is huge
and if you're a tortoise you can't
really run very fast but he does his
best runs across the paddock to see her
and just sits and and she tries to pat
him and she just ends up kind of like
hitting him on the head they love each
other it's the funniest thing you've
ever seen and i love that my daughter's
best friend
is a tortoise it's a 400 pound tortoise
that's awesome
it's so cool
of course you've brought a turtle to
this interview um what's the turtle's
name um yeah he's he's bruce senior he's
a bit of a diva to be honest yes
manny did you got yet real hard
[Music]
have you and chandler talked about more
kids i think right now for us we are so
happy with sweet space and we're having
so much fun reveling in her life that
we're just enjoying that's not what i
heard
oh okay i'm kidding i'm kidding
well for now it's little grace getting
in on the family business of wildlife
conservation and starring on crikey it's
the irwin's airing on animal planet and
discovery plus but she is leaving the
croc wrangling to her uncle robert
because well check out this tense moment
the most almost died sort of thing
yeah
a crop that we're that we're feeding was
actually rescued by it by my dad
he's coming out with such forces
i trip over
that's it
it's the first time i've ever actually
had to completely
ditch the food run jump over a fence
while there's a croc like right at your
heels and a massive dominant dominant
you'll have to watch to see if he
survives yeah yeah i might not make it
holy smokes i felt the breeze on that
one
bindi what is tougher
wrangling a crocodile or having a
newborn wow probably the new boy
crocodiles are pretty pretty simple
they're kind of just like one i'm gonna
eat you crocs like yeah i'm gonna eat
you yeah and that's about it you know
pretty much my baby's never said that
um bindi real quick speaking of
crocodiles i have to ask you about your
tattoo which is so beautiful i got
tattooed on my um graceful warrior
because that is my beautiful grace and
it's it's in my dad's handwriting which
is really special because i always have
dad how are you able to do that
it's dad's journals going back through
all of his journals
we were able to
piece it together
how would steve react knowing his
granddaughter is now on an irwin family
tv show showing the world the animals
that he loved
uh in a word he'd say crikey he's so
happy
[Music]
you